here's what would happen if you ate
nothing but caviar for a month
during the first part of this diet you
might actually feel some positive
effects your complexion might improve
your joints might feel better and even
your memory might get stronger but as
the month goes on you might start to
feel the effects of all that sodium
racing through your system you'd be
consuming up to 11 000 milligrams of
sodium every day more than five times
the daily requirement
consuming only this salty seafood would
make you very thirsty you'd start to
feel bloated and your hands and feet
would swell and you'd have problems
sleeping breathing and
urinating you might have seizures slip
into a coma or even die
and since you're not eating anything
that provides vitamin c you're at risk
of getting scurvy
early symptoms include nausea or
diarrhea but later on you might have
bruised scaly skin or bleeding gums and
we haven't even mentioned the cost of
caviar a month's supply of caviar could
cost you well over 60 thousand dollars
so